what is model identifiability in machine  learning  a model is identifiable if with a  sufficiently large  training set we can rule out all but  one parameter setting of the model  non-identifiability is the opposite when  multiple equivalent models give the same  outputs in a nutshell there are many  causes for model  non-identifiability for example weight  space symmetry  which happens when we rearrange the  hidden units and their  incoming and outgoing weight vectors  accordingly we get technically a  different model but  one delivering the same output model  non-identifiability could cause  infinitely many equivalent model  configurations and therefore potentially  infinitely many local minima but this is  not  the big problem for non-convex  optimization because  at least these local minima have  equivalent value  so the bad and the good local minima  proliferate all the same